Ну що ж цей час настав друзі всіх
вітаємо це Верховна Рада України і
останній цього важкого 23го року
пленарний
[музика]
тиждень 55 не наполягає 2 Чим менше мене
чутно тим менше у нас всіх Потім проблем
звичайно не нормально Що немає
журналістів у парламенті До речі
каналрада був один з небагатьох
допущених до прес-конференції президента
Зеленського і навіть там спромоглися
сформулювати питання не про парламент не
про те що й досі тут засідає опзж
заборонена партія що фактично немає
монобільшості ніякої тому що жоден закон
не приймається голосами сьогодні слуг
народу Ну немає 226 і це дуже складно
там є дефіцит пороху тощо у середу
Верховна Рада України прийняла кілька
дуже важливих законів які перезріли
навіть в першу чергу це зміни до
податкового кодексу яким було скасовано
ПДВ для ввезення імпорту або виробництва
в Україні обладнання радіоелектронної
боротьби системи реб треба налагодити
виробництва реб я Нагадую що моя команда
інвестувала 150 млн грвень в розробку
нової технології яка вже зараз садить
орлани і суперками нам потрібно більше
свого виробництва потрібно більше
звільнення від сплати податку на додану
вартість не тільки ввезених а і тих які
будуть вироблятися в Україні кінцевим
отримувачем цих товарів
є відповідно до сертифіката кінцевого
споживача всі підрозділи які зараз
захищають Україну Це дуже важливо Це
класна новина що 323 нардепи
конституційною більшістю проголосували
ці Ми сподіваємося що Президент
Зеленський оперативно їх підпише адже
наприклад уже кілька місяців Зеленський
не підписує закон так само прийнятий
конституційною більшістю
про списання швидке якщо менше на 100
000 є втрати військової техніки чи
обладнання в першу чергу мова іде про
Дрон традиційно парламентський тиждень
починається з виступів представників
фракцій і якраз Порошенко розповів про
свій останній візит на Сьогодні підранок
я повернувся з фронту і
сказати про те що там не вистачає
снарядів нічого не сказати це те що
кажуть наші
бійці сказати що не вистачає проти
повітряної оборони нічого не сказати і
ми маємо зробити все можливе для того
щоби прискорити надання від наших
партнерів цієї допомоги і держава має
налагодити серійне виро редині ї Ще раз
закликав негайно відкликати з
профільного комітету з нацбезпеки і
оборони неадекватну депутатку про
очищення комітету з нацбезпеки від
неадекватної особи яка поплюжить збройні
сили України Ще одне дуже важливе
рішення ми внесли зміни до Законів про
адміністративну процедуру в першому
читанні із базових рішень в цій сфері
але ми маємо завжди пам'ятати що диявол
в дрібницях тому тут потрібно не
забувати що має бути увага дуже
прискіплива до всіх норм щоб не вийшло
так що проводячи абсолютно правильне в
цілому рішення ми не створимо наприклад
корупційних ризиків от важливо до
другого читання тут допрацювати ті норми
які можуть звузити повноваження
місцевого самоврядування ті норми які
зараз прописані На жаль створюють таку
безпеку тому до другого читання будемо
доопрацьовувати взагалі це біч
нинішнього парламенту коли намагаються
чи не в кожному законі просяягти щось Що
звужує
повноваження децентралізації Ну і
нарешті парламент підійшов до таких
важких дискусій щодо законопроекту про
легалізацію медичного канабісу Ну що ж
цей час
[музика]
настав дивіться от коли ідуть
обговорення зала порожня знову хоча мова
іде про абсолютно принциповий для країни
законопроект без сумніву дуже дивує той
факт що зараз Як і завжди під час
обговорення таких важливих резонансних
законопроектів це відбувається в
порожній залі і це яскраве свідчення
незацікавленості народних депутатів
України багатьох розібратися про що
йдеться Сподіваюся взагалі 50 народних
депутатів насправді наша фракція подала
кілька при
для нас поправок Якими ми будемо
наполягати на посиленні державного
регулювання за виробництвом і обігом
медичного канабісу цей закон ключовий
Він має вирішити питання доступу
пацієнтів до ліків але ніяк не бізнесові
питання але ніяк не питання обігу
незаконного Я хотіла би щоби дійсно
комітет максимально був готовий
пропрацювати з колегами ті застереження
які ми маємо стосовно необхідності
реального контролю за
обігом цих речовин прозорих і зрозумілих
доступних для всіх правил які будуть
функціонувати і які впроваджує держава
щоби ми не відкрили скриньку Пандори і
під абсолютно правильним гаслом допомоги
пораненим і допомоги тим хто потребує не
відкрили безконтрольного виробництва і
Для нас це принципова позиція бо Чими є
цей проект це те що в одні руки віддано
виробництво контроль нагляд і подібні
речі позиція нашої фракції є однозначною
очевидно що онкохворі паліативні хворі
наші військові які мають
посттравматичний синдром повинні мати
право на достатнє лікування і
медпрепарати з використанням канабісу і
насправді уряд давнимдавно мав би це
зробити своїми підзаконними актами але
закон аніж його відсутність в залежності
від того чи будуть підтримані ці наші
поправки будемо визначатися з
голосуванням Це добре Да дуже важливо що
ми працювали із громадськими
організаціями які якраз підтримують
легалізацію медичного канабісу і вони
стоять теж на наших поправках шановна
Ірина Володимирівна ще раз підтверджую
що більшість поправок від вашої фракції
були дійсно фахові тільки медичний
канабіс тільки державне регулювання цієї
сфери дуже важливо і на цьому Ми
наполягаємо в наших поправках 291 не
наполягає 292 не наполягає
23 Чим менше мене чутно тим менше у нас
всіх Потім проблем на саме голосування
відбудеться вже у четвер На жаль ми не
встигли завершити розгляд питань порядку
денного на сьогодні друзі підписуйтеся
на наш YouTube канал тут правда про
роботу Верховної Ради України яка На
жаль сьогодні працює не прозоро і це
абсолютно неідповіда
збов'язанням України яка іде до ЄС і
НАТО парламент має бути сильним
незалежним і працювати 100% прозоро для
всіх українців